foreign
over Legacy and land that's happening
right now on Hilton Island
South Carolina 93. they fired all the
tenured people at CNN that's who they
have now or the young guys
Jesus Skippy give me just give me the
news then right now on Hilton island in
South Carolina Hilton Head Island South
Carolina 93 year old Josephine Wright is
at the center of a lawsuit it's picked
up attention Nationwide this development
goes up around her home she's literally
in the middle of what developers hope oh
she's one of those places it's not going
to sell
don't sell don't sell do not sell yeah I
love don't sell could be a new home
Community but for right so he's like
[__] y'all or CNN's Dan Gallagher
reports
we are connected I knew you all would
love this [__] oh my God this reminds
me of that episode of Better Call Saul
where they try to get that guy off his
land
yeah yeah runs through these trees no
matter what we will keep this land so
with this
make sure you have a will have a make
sure you have a will for your next of
kin I'm just just in case plan's gonna
be here with us if it's gonna be another
200 years I'm on her side immediately
yes I love this woman that's the way we
look at it but not everyone has that
same view the Serene Julie mcgreed
lawyer says we really need that we
really need that land to build a
development every development Steam
who's on the other side of Venice this
whole family their menaces they need to
be taken out of this community
Marsh and sandy beaches of Hilton Head
Island have been home to the galagichi
community since before America became
America Jesus Christ
so how long have they been there
wow these are people that have been
there for
ever
this black family has a [__] a deed
to the land that's carved in stone holy
[__]
it's written on lambskin
come on man so Dr jankos it's actually
was a condo Berg is very upset
Jeffrey condo Berg
but today community members say
development threatens those families who
still call it home why should we give up
such a precious gift amen amen you
shouldn't you shouldn't man God has
given us good Josephine Wright has lived
in this house on Hilton Head Island for
30 years you know what's funny it's like
not even a shitty house like it's not
even like it's it's no if they wanted to
build the development around her it's
not like she's going to be this [__]
eye so yeah it doesn't have a rundown
Trans Am in the yard you know what I
mean yeah exactly yeah she said the cars
parked in the [__] driveway [__]
this family oh yeah you got a Range
Rover it's her family's home has been on
this land since the Civil War actually a
nice little deck there you know what a
nice that's a cute little place leave
them alone I wouldn't give that [__] up
no [__] y'all just by Friedman and pass
down for Generations her husband a
Gullah descendant wanted to be sure to
keep the land in the family after his
passing I feel so much pride and come
comfort so so this was from the the
dude's [__] family yeah she's the
wife so this literally this old as [__]
lady honoring the wishes of her late
husband like I swear this this story
gets more and more old holy I love this
woman
knowing that this is weird if this was a
white woman she would have been like oh
God yeah you see how much they're
offering me yeah he's dead anyway I mean
what are you gonna do it will be for the
rest of my life but the 93 year old
great great grandmother has felt little
Comfort here of 93. for the past few
months this is when we start hearing the
trees say boom boom Wright is being sued
by a company with plans to build 147
three-story Town Homes along this
Jonesville Road
I don't know let's see community
neighborhood our Blood Sweat and Tears
are in this land my ancestors are buried
here down at the end of the road oh
that's the granddaughter today
construction is closing in around
Wright's modest talk showing her for
what she owns the land have as the
developer at any point come to you to
speak face to face about this no I've
never spoken to it virgin can you find
out what the lawsuit's about any one of
them they have never knocked on my door
she says about we're a little late to
break because I I we got it this is nuts
five years ago a woman did ask her about
selling the land to an interested
Anonymous buyer for thirty nine thousand
dollars [__] you oh you [__] off suck my
dick
and I said you insulted my intelligence
and would you give them that message
she says her first communication with
the company Bailey Point Investment LLC
was being served legal notice which
alleges a satellite dish a shed and a
portion of Rights screened in back porch
or sitting outside of her property line
encroaching on theirs according to their
land survey according to their list
according to their land oh okay yeah
the lawsuit seeks removal plus just an
adequate compensation for its loss of
the use and enjoyment of their property
and expenses related to delays in
development
whoa they're really trying to [__]
railroad [__] these people oh this
pisses me off oh this [__] pisses me
off Bailey Point says that the court
that little corner is on their property
so the issue is that corner look at
there with their dog like what a sweet
old lady yes Wright has filed a
countersuit alleging Bailey point and
their Affiliates are using harassment
and intimidation tactics to pressure her
off the land now Bailey Point has filed
a response denying any harassment as
well as any previous offers to purchase
her land yes they did but they did it
anonymously so they can't prove it she
has received an outpouring of support
and good 317k already
now guess what you're gonna tie your
asses up in court for [__] years for
you want that development to take
forever now it's gonna take forever from
celebrities like
Tyler Perry joins fight to help 93 year
old black woman hold on hold on
an NBA player Kyrie Irving
we love Kyrie around these parts I love
Kyrie Kyrie rules okay you know what
[__] yeah you're [__] awesome
oh they're gonna have to they're gonna
have to drop this whole [__] thing
now they're gonna have to drop it and
their whole development's gonna look
weird and awkward No One's Gonna Be this
little junk out of it forever like
they'll still finish the development but
it's gonna be all [__] up now I'm I'm
loving this
the town of Hilton Head just announced
it is pausing all Construction in line
with us
oh no this isn't going away at all oh
[__] they're pot I take it back I guess
that development ain't getting finished
we have a lot of black pills we have to
swallow all the time this is good this
is good
you know what the best part is after all
this is [__] settled this [__] is
Gonna Come ahead and you know what she's
gonna do with that money she's gonna buy
up more land I would yeah
it's mine now
and had just announced it is pausing all
Construction in line with their town
code refusing to issue Bailey Point
building permits
[Laughter]
funniest [__] ever dude all they had to
do and we always say all they had to do
was say nothing all they had to do was
litter keep her porch and she probably
would have been she wouldn't she would
have had stuff built around her but she
but she'd still have her land and she
probably would sit there with like that
little house around all these condos and
she'd be the happiest person there but
instead you get this good oh my God but
Josephine right isn't alone in her fight
she speaks too I didn't even watch this
whole story when I threw it in prep I
just seen like this lady getting [__]
by corporations I had no idea it had to
happen who good what culture and the
Gullah desire
to fight back Luana Graves sellers runs
a non-profit called The Low Country
Gullah Foundation focused on helping
prevent land loss in the galagichi
community it's like that there was this
that's actually that's not a joke but
remember that TV show back in the day on
Nickelodeon Gullah Gullah Island the
kids show yeah literally based off of
their these people this this place
like not her house but the islands
around there to me it's that sense it's
about her that's about that lady yeah
she's the Frog and Island became a
vacation destination sorry pollywog
Nation after Mainland Bridge was built
in the 1950s the galagichi have lost
nearly two-thirds of their acreage
mostly due to Rising property taxes and
problems with something called Ayers
property how pervasive is that on this
island now it's pervasive here but it's
pervasive throughout the South and
unfortunately Air's property is the
primary way that black people in America
are losing their land Ayers property is
a type of 12-pack says I'm amazed they
didn't film her crying because this
[__] doesn't cry that's why no that 93
year old woman doesn't cry unless it's
like a relative passes so because she's
that's a hard [__] good for her [__]
these people land ownership where a
single property may be inherited by
multiple members of a family for
Generations after the original owner
passes away but there's often a lack of
clear legal documentation making
families vulnerable to land loss when
there are disagreements within the
family overselling some of these cases
here the land is being purchased by
developers just look at this
this is one of the most peaceful and
honestly where she I'm on her side about
this too that area is beautiful like
yeah leave it alone
you know we need multi-family dwellings
areas and lost by the goligichi but in
the case of affordable housing Virgie
Josephine Wright she's standing firm on
her ground well let me put a TV this way
I've never backed down on on anything
that would yeah this [__] don't look
like she's ever back down also 93 and
all there unlike Biden or McConnell that
says he's 93 and [__] Sharp
now on the past couple months leading up
to this week CNN has repeatedly reached
out to Bailey
now she's made out of an Instagram
filter anyone that we could find
associated with the project a name
developer did respond telling us that
they're not the developer of the excuse
me unnamed organizer did respond telling
us they're not the developer of the
project but rather an investment company
that financed the deal but if we reach
out to lawyers for bayley Point we've
reached out to the architect even the
engineer for the proposed subdivision
none have responded meanwhile Josephine
I wouldn't either are you the [__]
nuts you guys would be you're boned
you're [__] now you're [__] and you
should be [__] and then and you know
what I'm also glad about they didn't
turn into a racial issue you never heard
her sick I'm a proud black no no she was
like no I live here this is my [__]
property no and I always side with get
the [__] off my property that's the one
thing that I will 100 I don't care what
your politics are yeah get the [__] off
that yeah [__] off her property get off
her [__] property
doesn't matter who you are do not [__]
with people's land I hate that [__] and
they do that and they use the domain
laws you know what you know
some of the [__] they've done [__] them
yeah it's for eminent domain's one of
the most evil things yeah absolutely
ever absolutely really is uh don't you
L.A fire you guys saying you don't want
private Equity firms owning 49 of all
residential housing in the U.S
contributing to astronomical housing and
rent prices yes that's exactly what
we're saying
the betsoft says I would rather have the
92 year old black lady as my neighbor
yeah she probably makes killer lemonade
and [__] you know yeah she probably
makes the best [__] peach cobbler
we've ever had any goddamn life
black Rock's never going to make me
peach cobbler her cornbread
cornbread her collards bro
cornbread too